why don't you just be yourself
because there's nothing about me that's
relatable the weekend is responding to
the backlash over his series The Idol
kind of care what people
this after fans called out a
cringe-worthy sex scene in episode 2 of
the HBO show in an interview with GQ
Magazine the weekend whose real name is
Abel tesfay addresses the criticism
saying there's nothing sexy about the
scene that's the way the world could see
what I'm looking at right now the show
has been surrounded by controversy even
before it aired with some critics
calling it revenge porn and 50 Shades of
test Faye Los Angeles is where all the
monsters of the world come together
the weekend goes on to tell the mag
however you're feeling watching that
scene it's all those emotions adding up
to this guy is in way over his head this
situation is one where he is not
supposed to be here trust no one just
in the series The Weekend plays a modern
day quote leader who promises the world
to an up-and-coming pop singer played by
Lily Rose Depp rivaling comparisons to a
certain real-life pop star I watched the
first two episodes and I was like whoa
when audiences see this show they're
gonna make comparisons of this pop star
Jocelyn with none other than Britney
Spears who were you actually thinking of
when you were creating this woman in
this character
of course there's so many incredible pop
stars of today that I that I you know
have nothing but admiration and respect
for and of course that you can't help
but think of when you're thinking about
um a character like Jocelyn we're
definitely not telling anybody else's
story or or trying to base her on any
any real person while the idol is not
based on fact it is taking the viewers
on one purposeful Wild Ride Abel who
also created the show tells GQ with this
show we love to play with the emotions
or puppet mastering your feelings
through the show it's never a consistent
tone and that's on purpose can I be your
best friend I'd love to get paid he goes
on to say no matter how dark a scene is
you can find the comedy in it he's
brainwashed sure
[Music]